[Music]
she was so sweet kind of a bird but so
sweet
I told her black ass to never leave
Atlanta I heard Kelly be on a [ __ ]
I mean yeah we went to prom together but
we haven't talked in years
I thought she been dead I don't think
she did she chilling with packing them
you know they ain't looking nobody cares
when our girls go missing
on the afternoon of July 23rd 2019 a 26
year old Latoya Thompson walked into a
Red Lobster on Crenshaw and century but
she never quite made it to those warm
cheddar Bay biscuits what happened
who's responsible did anyone see this
coming could anyone have stopped it
it's Latoya just missing or was she
murdered we won't stop until we find out
I'm rose cranberry and this is looking
for Latoya
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she told me her boyfriend was having
problems they always arguing this
particular day I'm in my car I looked at
the window I was like nah they don't
look right it looked dangerous I know he
knows them did he do it
I knew the only way I could solve this
case was to talk to her boyfriend
boyfriend whoa whoa whoa whoa chill
chill chill on that she said that I mean
you know we was talking I did I hit yes
yes I hit I didn't kill her at all I
mean I killed [ __ ] you know my
condolences to her moms and pops you
know I don't know where she at though he
did it I know he did it I know it in my
heart no baby look we don't know that
for sure
we don't have it look a little look all
we can do is have faith and pray I know
my baby's out there and we're not gonna
give up any little thing we'll help
it's snapchat photos any Instagram
whatever you got on that little and
don't trust his ass baby you can say no
because it's been almost two months
since Latoya went missing and the cops
still have no leads I met with the lead
detective on a case to try and get some
answers we have put as many resources as
we can towards finding Toyota we put her
photo up all around the city we've held
several press conferences I want to
assure the good people of Los Angeles
that we are doing everything in our
power to ensure the safe return of this
lost Toyota sir again this is the case
about the missing african-american girl
Latoya Thompson not a missing vehicle no
further comment at this time
sir
sir we set up a special tip line for the
public to call in with any leads it's
2019 who calls anymore right send the
text [ __ ] where's the volume button
thank you I don't know what to tell ya
this car does not want to be found
I spoke with Stacy and Travis who both
work at Red Lobster which was Latoya's
last seen location I knew something was
up when she came in with the white boy
mm-hmm her acting coach they came for
the cheddar biscuits out the class so
are you saying she was having an affair
I know damn snitch
after learning this tasty tidbit I know
it was time for me to have a talk with
this shatter Bay she was not a good
actor but she was very beautiful and had
a really big heart I went but I couldn't
stay long I had a missed lunch for this
big audition I got a callback for the
Simi Valley Junior College repertory
production of Sons of Anarchy the
musical I did not get the part but now
they know me
who do you have playing me this is the
moment we've all been waiting for
ladies and gentlemen Latoya is here yes
so everyone get up
[Applause]
all right let's go have a seat honey so
where have you been I was working on a
Disney cruise I got booked as their
first black Ariel
I'm sweet about it but I have three
followers on my pages private so why
didn't you call or text anyone
ain't no service on a cruise but I did
email on my parents no you know I don't
lay up for what that's why I got a
secretary I don't even a lot of time you
need to know how to check a damn email
hello I'm sorry I take some time get
them out so anyway while Latoya was
missing the inner city Los Angeles
Police Department was able to find 22
missing white women and here they aren't
in the scrub
anyone you know nope mm-hmm well anyway
Latoya now that you were found what do
you want to do next
well first I'm gonna thank you for all
your hard work even I wasn't missing for
real it means a lot that you found me
thank you
secondly I'm talking about oxygen about
the new streaming service oxygen plus -
now and they wanna do a whole new show
about finding missing black our new show
we they look at what it can I be missing
it yeah great we all stay looking for
you too
[Applause]
you
you